martin restent concernées par un risque
de pluies abondantes
je voudrais dire que pour météo france
chacun a pu constater effectivement
qu'il n'a pas plu jusqu'à présent mais
ce risque il existe pour l'après midi
est pour même la soirée c'est ce que
nous dit météo france alors est-ce que
nous allons rester en vigilance rouge
ok ce qu'il va se passer donc on va
maintenir la vigilance rouge pour
l'ensemble de la journée de jeudi
et puis nous ferons un point en fin de
journée sans doute en fin d'après-midi
pour regarder la situation pour demain
les mesures pour demain afin que chacun
puisse s'organiser
donc il faut bien le dire à la
population que nous sommes toujours en
vigilance rouge et que les mesures
s'appliquent donc l'interdiction de
sortir et de rester chez soi observe les
mesures de sécurité oui il faut dire à
la population qu'il y à un risque
dangereux de pluies abondantes
vous savez pour les prévisionnistes de
météo france le risque pluie est plus
compliqué à gérer
il nous avait dit que nous aurions des
vagues en dans l'atlantique de 3 à 4
mètres c'est le cas ils nous avaient dit
que ces vagues pour la caraïbe serait
inhabituel c'est bien le cas ils nous
avaient dit et je m'en félicite que nous
n'aurions pas de vents cycloniques et
c'est le cas et donc je voudrais
vraiment remercier les prévisionnistes
de météo france
et donc ce qu'il nous dit c'est que pour
la fin de journée la soirée il y à ce
risque de pluies abondantes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour toute la
journée
la martinique demeurent en alerte rouge